also wir haben recherchiert zu Bill
Gates und seinem Netzwerk das Netzwerk
was die Bill Gate Foundation die größte
Stiftung der Welt umgibt und wie die in
der corona-pandemie agiert haben wir
haben festgestellt dass sowohl die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO als auch
die Nationalstaaten keinen wirklichen
Plan hatten wie sie jetzt agieren sollen
wie sie auf diese Größe Krise diese
größte weltweite Krise eigentlich
reagieren sollten was sie tun sollten
und da gab es so ein Vakuum auf das die
Bill Gates Foundation draufgegangen ist
und gesagt hat wir wissen wie es geht
wir haben dann relativ schnell Fakten
geschaffen haben gesagt welche Geld
fließt wohin auf welche
impfstoffentwickler liegen wir uns fest
und anderthalb Jahre später hat man
festgestellt dass die Pläne aber nicht
aufgegangen sind das also sozusagen ein
Netzwerk was überhaupt nicht
demokratisch legitimiert war Fakten
geschaffen hat und diese Fakten aber im
Grunde genommen dazu geführt haben dass
Afrika vor allen Dingen nicht richtig
versorgt waren mit Impfstoff mit
Medikamenten und mit Testkits es rank
sehr viele Verschwörungstheorien um Bill
Gates es war habe ich auch in einem
Interview gelesen das war auch so der
Aufhänger warum sie und das Team sieben
Monate lang recherchiert haben
welche Verschwörungstheorien sind denn
richtig welche sind falsch also wenn ich
jetzt jemand nach heute abend sage so
schätze ich Bill Gates ein was sollte
ich sagen also Verschwörungstheorien
sind sowieso generell alle falsch die
sich um Bill Gates Ranken also es gibt
ja da diese wilden Theorien dass Bill
Gates irgendwie durch Impfungen Leuten
Chips eingepflanzt hätte das ist
natürlich totaler Unsinn und ich glaube
das ist aber auch ein bisschen der Grund
warum seriös recherchierende
Journalisten bei diesem Thema ganz lange
abgeschreckt waren und gesagt haben an
das Thema gehen wir überhaupt nicht
kritisch ran und gucken uns überhaupt
nicht kritisch das Wirken dieser
Foundation an obwohl die so ein ganz
großer wichtiger Player ist eigentlich
der größte Spieler in der weltweiten
Gesundheitspolitik und wir haben dann
gesagt wir gucken uns jetzt mal ganz
strukturiert an was hat diese Stiftung
seit Beginn der Pandemie gemacht wo
haben die Geld angesammelt von wem wie
viel was haben die für ein Lobbying
gemacht um dieses Geld zu bekommen was
haben sie dann mit dem Geld getan und
was ist am Ende dabei rausgekommen und
was man halt sagen kann ist tatsächlich
um es auf die Frage nach den
Verschwörungstheorien zurückzukommen
dass die einfach diejenigen sind die die
weltweite Gesundheitspolitik am meisten
bestimmen obwohl sie niemand gewählt hat
und obwohl es auch keine richtigen
Aufsichtsgremien gibt die das Wirken der
Gates Foundation und ihrer mit ihnen
verbündeten anderen Stiftungen
kontrollieren also bis vor relativ
kurzer Zeit saßen im Aufsichtsrat der
Gates Foundation Bill Gates seine Frau
sein Vater und der Milliardär Warren
Buffett der wiederum einer größten
Geldgeber der Gates Foundation ist und
die Nationalstaaten sowie Deutschland
die USA die wiederum viel Geld geben an
die Stiftung die es dann weiter verteilt
haben überhaupt keine Möglichkeit zu
kontrollieren was passiert mit dem Geld
die geldstiftung unterstützt ja auch
einzelne Medien das ist ihnen vielleicht
auch bei der Recherche begegnet das ist
aber noch mal so ein anderer Punkt also
es gibt ja zum Beispiel den Spiegel der
eine Finanzierung mal bekommen hat für
spezielle Projekte die er dann gemacht
hat das ist aber jetzt was anderes das
haben wir uns jetzt nicht so angeguckt
ne also wir haben uns ja wirklich nur
das Wirken der Stiftung in der
corona-pandemie angeguckt es gibt aber
wahnsinnig viele Stiftungen
Organisationen in Deutschland auch die
Geld bekommen von der Stiftung und man
kann schon sagen die ist wie so ein naja
also wie so ein Spieler der hat überall
seine Arme drin und der kann einfach
wahnsinnig viel bewegen und viele Themen
auch auf die Agenda der Politik setzen
und wenn jetzt sagen uns ist am
wichtigsten diese Krankheit zu bekämpfen
und nicht jene dann passiert das auch
also wenn ich es einmal zusammenfasse
würden Sie sagen dass die Bill Gates und
Melinda French Gates sie heißt jetzt
wieder Mädchen am Arsch mittlerweile
angenommen hat genau mittlerweile leben
sie ein Trennung arbeiten aber ja noch
zusammen würden Sie sagen jetzt diese
Stiftung faktisch die Politik bestimmt
ja zu großen Teilen schon also unser
unsere Recherche wir haben uns da auch
so angeguckt
über auskunftsanfragen an die
Bundesregierung zum Beispiel mit wem hat
sich Bill Gates und Melinda French Gates
zu welchem Zeitpunkt aus der deutschen
Politik getroffen und wir haben dann zum
Beispiel Unterlagen aus dem Kanzleramt
noch aus der Zeit von Angela Merkel
bekommen wo man dann sehen konnte zum
Beispiel an dem und dem Tag hat Bill
Gates bei Angela Merkel angerufen vorher
da ging es um die Frage ob der
Patentschutz gelockert werden sollte für
Impfstoffe gegen Corona woher hatte
Angela Merkel gesagt na ich könnte mir
schon vorstellen ich schwanke noch
vielleicht könnte es in dem Fall mal
sinnvoll sein das auszuprobieren nach
dem Telefonat hat sie dann sagen lassen
durch die Regierungssprecher nee wir
müssen beim Patentschutz bleiben das
sind nur so kleine Indizien man weiß
jetzt nicht hat er wirklich gesagt Frau
Merkel sie müssen aber und ich glaube
auch eine bessere Frau Merkel so so
lässt sich ja auch nicht steuern wie
eine Marionette die wird sich schon
durch Argumente haben hat überzeugen
lassen aber es sind eben die Indizien
was ja einfach für eine Wirkmacht hat
das heißt dass er auch den direkten
Draht hat und sagt ich rufe an Frau
Merkels am Telefon es sind eigentlich
Indizien dafür dass Bill Gates auch den
deutschen corona-kurs mitbestimmt hat
absolut nicht nur in deutschen sondern
den weltweiten
Helene Mann wenn Sie das als Politiker
hören dann denke ich als erstes Wahnsinn
die wichtig Journalismus ist ich will
gar nicht wissen wie lange das gedauert
hat was sie da gemacht haben also stark
sie haben doch vermutlich als sie die
Teesorte gelesen haben auch erstmal eine
Verschwörungstheorie gedacht als sie es
gelesen ich habe auch erstmal
recherchiert weil ich kenne natürlich
viele weltweite Organisationen und die
sind
den Faktor auch für die Daseinsvorsorge
da so eine who muss ja schauen dass es
weltweit eine Koordinierung gibt etc und
immer wenn es um Daseinsvorsorge gibt
haben privatwirtschaftliche Interessen
keine Chance oder sollten es nicht haben
und deswegen ist es extrem wichtig
gleichzeitig ist die wao natürlich in
den letzten Jahren irgendwie auch
runtergekommen die waren irgendwie froh
dass die Spenden bekommen haben von den
privaten und das war dann der
Zielkonflikt und die privaten haben
gesagt wenn ich euch Geld gebe will ich
auch mitreden das geht natürlich nicht
bei einer who genau also das habe ich
eben erst noch nicht so ausführlich
gesagt also die Nationalstaaten
Deutschland USA Großbritannien die haben
in den letzten Jahren immer weniger Geld
an die WHO gegeben und deswegen konnte
die WHO ja eigentlich für diese
Bewältigung von globalen
gesundheitskrisen zuständig sein sollte
das nicht mehr so machen die war nicht
mehr so ein richtiger operativer Akteur
sondern die ist eigentlich nur noch zur
Verwaltung von Krankheiten und zu ihrer
Erfassung da deswegen hat sich überhaupt
die Bill Gates Stiftung irgendwann
gegründet zum Jahrtausendwechsel und hat
gesagt da gibt's ja eine Lücke da muss
doch jetzt mal jemand aktiv werden und
dann haben die sozusagen gesagt so und
das ist ja auch da kann man ihn auch
dankbar für sein dass die überhaupt mal
weil Nationalstaaten und wir haben
könnte eigentlich auch sagen dass die
Bill Gates und Melinda French Gadget die
auch die größte private der Welt ist
dass die schon mächtiger ist als die who
also auf jeden Fall ist die WHO sehr
stark von ihr abhängig die sind zuletzt
der Größe größte einzelne Geldgeber
gewesen und es gibt auch ein ziemlich
großen personellen Austausch zwischen
der Gates Stiftung und den anderen mit
ihr verknüpfen Stiftung und der who also
das ist so eine ziemlich kleine
Community von globalen
Gesundheitsexperten und die kennen sich
alle und die Stimmen sich ab und dann
geht der eine mal dahin und der andere
geht mal dahin und das ist so eine
verschwommene Gemeinschaft und da ist
schon die bildmilinda Gates Foundation
der
mächtigste Spieler da habe ich ihn als
letzte Frage für heute eine suggestive
stellen die müssen Sie auch nicht
beantworten wenn Sie nicht möchten weil
ich weiß dass sie suggestiv ist aber
glauben sie nach ihren Recherchen das
vielleicht sogar die corona-politik
anders verlaufen wäre ohne die Stiftung
ja auf jeden Fall dann ohne die
starke Einflussnahme der Gates
Foundation darauf dass dieser
Patentschutz auf die Impfstoffe
unbedingt erhalten bleiben musste hätte
es sehr wahrscheinlich mal anders
ausprobiert werden können dass man in
Afrika gesagt hätte wir entwickeln wir
wir stellen jetzt hier selber die
Medikamente her ob das geklappt hätte
oder nicht weiß kein Mensch es gibt ja
auch gute Gründe dafür man braucht den
Patentschutz sagt Bill Gates und sagen
natürlich auch viele andere die
marktwirtschaftlich denken man braucht
Patentschutz weil sonst würde kein
impfstoffentwickler ein Anreiz haben
sowas jemals nochmal zu machen aber es
gab durchaus die Debatte zu sagen hier
ist eine noch nie dagewesene
Herausforderung für die Welt und
vielleicht hat man es einfach mal
ausprobieren können in dem Fall